Russian Federation
we don't yet have all information from
the territory
that is currently occupied
but from what is not
foreign
little personalities who did not even
have time to see what life is like
like one of the youngest casualties on
the war
two day old Sergey
two day old
say boy
did not live long enough
to be given a birth certificate
he was killed
by Russian rocket
in the maternity house
about 2 am on Wednesday as his mom Maria
had just finished nursing the child and
laid him down to sleep in the crib
beside you
a rocket crashed into the hospital's
maternity ward
the hospital walls came crumbling down
trapping the woman
and her infant
in the rubble
slash L8 and Es a slash es 11 L9
foreign
excellencies
distinguished delegates
today we Mark the Grim first anniversary
of the warrior in Ukraine
one year of Despair
displacement destruction and Death on a
scale of not seen in Europe indicates
The Staggering scale of loss defy the
human ability to absorb
thousands of civilians and soldiers dead
countless more injured
eight million refugees
prayed across Europe and Beyond
six million internally displaced
two-thirds of them women and children
with families separated often not
knowing about the fate of their loved
ones
and the systemic targeting of Civilian
infrastructure
which has left millions of ukrainians
without energy water and heat in the
depth of winter
to be clear
the targeting of Civilian infrastructure
is a direct violation of international
humanitarian law
when these are the headlines of our day
we are indeed in a new chapter of
History
we are facing stock choices
about Who We Are
as an International Community
and how we will rebuild the trust lost
Among Us
here in this hole and in US
by the peoples of the world
the choices
will either set us on a path of
solidarity and Collective resolve to
uphold the tenets of the U.N Charter
or a path of aggression
War
normalize the violations of
international law
and collapsed Global action
excellencies the general assembly has
condemned in the strongest terms
Russia's aggression against Ukraine
and it's morally and legally
indefensible war against its Sovereign
neighbor
for a full year the Gen assembly
the Secretary General and the
International Community have been
consistent and vocal in our cause to end
this war
and to adhere to the U.N Charter and
international law
but it Bears repeating today
aggression is illegal
invading a neighbor
is illegal
annexing in other countries territory
over the past year
every member states represented in this
whole has been affected by these events
it has sparked an energy crisis across a
continent
and caused pernicious inflation far
beyond
it has Unleashed a global food security
crisis in those least able to survive
one
from the drought effect affected Horn of
Africa
to warn tone Yemen
to refugee camps of Syria
I comment the Black Sea grain initiative
and efforts by the Secretary General
Ukraine and the Russian Federation to
ensure the clearance of food experts for
Global markets
I call on the parties to support it it's
renewable in March and to expedite
inspections
they continued And Timely implementation
of the grain initiative is critical to
saving lives and stabilizing Global
prices
it offers a strong example of Crisis
Management in action
against this backdrop
the threats of nuclear warfare still
loans launch
as do
the dangers of a nuclear accident
catastrophic Global consequences
nuclear safety in Ukraine yep
and the non-proliferation regime
excellencies
no one can be come can be complacent
to all those suffering the consequences
of this war
you are not forgotten
we see you
we hear you
across the U.S system we are working
tirelessly to find solution to your
plight
and to accompany you on the road to
reconstruction
I comment member states that have
already begun to provide assistant that
assistant
and call for further support to rebuild
the country
in the Gen assembly there has been Firm
support for a political solution
free resolutions adopted during the 11th
emergency special session have
referenced political dialogue
negotiations
mediations or other peaceful means
a solution based on the U.N Charter and
international law
and one that respects Ukraine's
sovereignty
and territorial Integrity within its
internationally recognized borders
excellencies
this war
will come to an end
and the time of reconstruction
reconciliation and transformation
welcome
we know it will not be easy
we know the scars are deep
culture
family bonds
Sports arts and the acknowledgment of
the shared Destiny of humanity will
certainly help Nations currently facing
each other in the trenches
and people of the Russian Federation
Russia yes and remains amazing member of
the community of Nations other members
to come back to the pathway of bringing
in and sustaining peace so as to bring
in its own contribution to General
stability and well-being your
excellencies
let this one year
and this suffering of the millions of
people in front of our eyes over the
past years
a reminder here in this room
military Solutions will not put an end
to the war
too many lives have been lost
far too many livelihoods and families
and local communities Russia
Russia must put an end to this hellish
spilling of blood
I call on on the parties and the
International Community to recommit to
the values principles and purposes of
the United U.N Charter
upholding and preserving our
constitution for we the peoples
must be common interest to all member
states
there is no alternative I thank you
I now invite the Secretary General of
the United Nations his Excellency
Antonio will tell us to make a statement
foreign
assembly excellencies ladies and
gentlemen
the one-year Mark of Russia's invasion
of Ukraine stands as a green milestone
for the people of Ukraine and for the
International Community
that invasion is an affront to our
Collective conscience
it is a violation of United Nations
Charter and international law
it is having dramatic humanitarian and
human rights consequences
and the impact is being felt far beyond
Ukraine
as I said from day one Russia's attack
on Ukraine challenges the Cornerstone
principles and values of our
multilateral system
Divine Charter is unambiguous and I
quote
all members shall refrain in their
international relations from the threat
or use of force against the territorial
Integrity or political independence of
any state
or in any other manner inconsistent with
the purposes of the United Nations
Mr President excellencies
the general assembly has addressed in
the clearest terms the attempt by the
Russian Federation to illegally Annex
four regions of Ukraine kerson saporizia
Donetsk and luhansk
in doing so the assembly reaffirmed the
long-standing principles of
international law contained in its
Landmark friendly elections Declaration
of 1970.
namely that and I quote
the territory of a state shall not be
the object of acquisition by another
state
resulting from the threat or user Force
and that no territorial acquisition
shall be recognized as legal
end of quote
the position of United Nations is
unequivocal
we are committed to the sovereignty
Independence unity and territorial
Integrity of Ukraine within its
internationally recognized borders
Mr President
United Nations
are in need of humanitarian assistance
have been destroyed in the dead of
winter
this organizations
since the Second World War
ehouse support
foreign
[Music]
Mr President
even amidst the brutality of War
we have worked in concerted and creative
ways to forge Solutions
in Mario Paul the United Nations helped
evacuate civilians trapped in the as of
style still plan
the Black Sea grain initiatives has
shown the possibility of Ukraine and
Russia to advance Global Food security
with the support of government of turkey
and the United Nations
despite ongoing challenges the
initiative to ship grain and other
foodstuffs from Ukraine is making a
difference
we are working hard to remove all
remaining obstacles to the
implementation of the memorandum of
understanding between the Secretariat of
United Nations and the Russian
Federation to facilitate exports of
Russian foods and fertilizers to Global
markets
this is also an important contribution
to address Global Foods in security
and will continue to support these
initiatives for the benefit of millions
of people across the world especially in
the global South
notwithstanding deep mistrust the
parties to conflict
have also worked out regularly changed
the prisons of War facilitated by
Regional actors
these efforts can and must continue
and expand as much as possible
it's the president
over the past year
not only have we seen suffering and
devastating grow
it is also becoming more evident just
how much worse it could all still become
the possible consequences of a spiraling
Conflict at a clear and present danger
every day
we are reminded of the graves threat
that tells us all when irresponsible
military activity continues around the
zaporizian nuclear power plant
the largest nuclear facility in Europe
I command the international atomic
energy and the atomic energy Agency for
engaging the sides to ensure the area
remains safe
security and safety of all Ukrainian
nuclear power plants must be guaranteed
the war is also Fanning Regional
instability and fooling Global tensions
and divisions while diverting attention
and resources from other crises and
pressing Global issues
meanwhile we have heard implicit threats
to use nuclear weapons
the so-called tactical use of nuclear
weapons is utterly unacceptable
it is high time to step back from the
brink complacency will open deepen the
crisis while further eroding our shared
principles proclaimed in the charter
Mr President excellencies war is not the
solution
war is the problem
people in Ukraine are suffering
enormously
ukrainians Russians and people far
beyond need peace
and while prospects may look Bleak today
we must all work
knowing that genuine lasting peace must
be based on the event Charter and
international law
the longer the finding continues the
more difficult this work will be
we don't have a moment to lose and I
thank you
I thank the Secretary General
I now give the flow to his Excellency
dimitro culeba Minister of Foreign
Affairs of Ukraine to introduce draft
resolution a slash es 11 L7
Mr President
distinguished Representatives
one year since the Russian Federation
began its full-scale aggression against
Ukraine is approaching
I stood here
at this esteemed place exactly one year
ago
it was February 23rd
24 hours before the aggression began
a massive Russian Force hung over
Ukraine preparing to deal a devastating
blow to my country
and wipe it off the face of the world
map
the first strikes hit the country early
in the morning
ever since then Ukraine exercised its
legitimate right to self-defense
enshrined in the U.N Charter
the Ukrainian people made a choice
fight for their lives
and Against All Odds
we were able to stop the much stronger
aggressor and kick him out of half of
the newly occupied territory of our
country
but even after failing so badly and
losing so many
Russia still wants to destroy Ukraine
as a Sovereign Nation
and no one should be fooled by Russia's
empty calls
for negotiations
the current situation on the front line
proves
they want war
not peace
they are on the attack all along the
front line from the nipple River
to the Russian border
they keep striking Ukraine's civilian
infrastructure with salvas of Cruz
missiles
made in Russia and drones
made in Iran
this is why we have no choice but to
keep fighting for our survival
as any of you would do
the world has seen terrible atrocities
committed by Russians in the occupied
territories
murder of unarmed civilians torture and
rape looting Terror political
persecution
in discriminate shelling as well as
deliberate attacks on civilian
infrastructure
forcible transfers of and deportations
of thousands of Ukrainian children and
their consequent adoption in Russian
families in order to re-educate them as
Russians
this is a genocide
and this is what we face today
for Ukraine giving up would mean that
such atrocities would be committed all
over our territory
and I'm confident that Any Nation
represented in this chamber would do the
same in our place you would fight
I know that some still think
and sometimes say
we want to be friends with both Ukraine
and Russia
let it all just end sooner with whatever
result
I can understand that
the problem is that in this war there
are no two equal sides
there is an aggressor
and a victim
I understand that there are still some
countries that do not want to take
Ukraine's site for various reasons
but it's not about that it's about
taking the side of the United Nations
Charter
it's about taking the side of
international law
it is about taking the side of the U.N
General Assembly resolutions
these are our common rules
and we are all interested in upholding
them
who is the exception of the Russian
Federation which thinks that rules do
not apply to it and exist only to be
violated
we are all talking about peace today but
what is peace
the freedom of the occupier to rule over
the land he has ravaged
impunity for war criminals
a respite and a chance to prepare for a
new war and new crimes
we will only worsen the problem if we
replace one ugly reality with another
and call it peace
throughpiece came in 1945 not because
the forces of good stopped fighting that
because evil was defeated
peace means
Justice
three months ago President Vladimir
zielinski outlined our vision for
ensuring comprehensive just and
long-term peace in Ukraine as well as
Global Security the peace formula
this plan is based on 10 points
one
radiation and nuclear safety
two
food security
three energy security
four release of prisoners and deported
persons
five implementation of the UN Charter to
restore territorial sovereignty of
Ukraine within its internationally
recognized borders
six withdrawal of Russian troops and
cessation of hostilities
seven restoration of Justice including
with the creation of a special Tribunal
eight prevention of echocyte
nine prevention of escalation of war and
repetition of aggression
and 10. confirmation of the end of the
war
this vision is realistic and true to the
facts it covers all areas where peace
needs to be restored
IT addresses the real needs and
challenges faced by the people who
suffer from this war
each of these steps can be implemented
if there is a strong will for peace
among many nations
and if we all unite our efforts around
the same goal
instead of hiding behind the mask of
neutrality let's choose the side of the
U.N Charter and international law
ladies and gentlemen never in recent
history has the line between good and
evil has been so clear
one country
merely wants to live in peace
and I represent that country
the other
wants to kill and destroy and it has its
Representatives too
there is no other country in the world
that wants peace as much as Ukraine does
we never wanted War
we never planned to attack anyone
our troops do not stand on anyone else's
land
we exercise our legitimate right to
self-defense
and do it pretty effectively
we know what we are fighting for
we are defending our land our families
and our homes
can anyone tell what Russians Die For in
a foreign land
this is why calls to cease delivery of
weapons and ammunition to Ukraine are
badly misplaced
it is perfectly legitimate to help a
nation that has been attacked and is
justifiably defending itself
it is an act of defense of the U.N
Charter
it is an act in favor of ending the War
sooner and achieving a lasting and just
peace
on the contrary
it is illegal and against the U.N
Charter to give military help to the
aggressor
it is an act of War escalation and
prolongation of atrocities destruction
and sufferings
the principle of territorial Integrity
cannot be compromised
is there anyone in this room who is
ready to give away one square meter of
its territory to a bloodthirsty neighbor
we all know the answer
there is none
and Ukraine is one of you
the world will drown in chaos if we
allow changing borders by force under
the disguise of political expediency or
sympathy towards aggressor
with the support of the world Ukraine
can restore its territorial integrity
and respect for the U.N Charter and it
will
and this will discourage Russia and
other aggressors from wanting to attack
other nations
to achieve this Noble goal we need to
send a strong and clear message that the
U.N Charter including the principles of
sovereign equality and territorial
Integrity of States should serve as the
basis for the process of peaceful
resolution
I therefore call on members of the
United Nations to support draft
resolution entitled
principles underlying a comprehensive
just and Lasting peace in Ukraine the
aforementioned resolution will
contribute
to our joint efforts to bring the war to
an end as well as protect the
fundamental principles of international
law and the U.N Charter
and again exactly a year ago I was
standing here appealing
to the Nations United in this whole on
the need to prevent War
a year after Against All Odds
Ukraine is effectively defending itself
against a much stronger enemy and I
appeal to you this is a decisive moment
to show support
Unity
and solidarity
this is the moment to prove that you
stand for the U.N Charter in words and
in Deeds
thank you for your attention
[Laughter]
I thank the Minister of Foreign Affairs
of Ukraine
I now give the flow to their
distinguished representative of Belarus
to introduce draft amendments contained
in document a slash es11 L8 and a slash
es11 L9
um
distinguished colleagues
and Ukraine
purpose of these images
we will have the opportunity to
familiarize yourselves
the objective of the Amendments is to
ratify
inaccuracies where
[Music]
military potential which no one would
wish for if this were the case I don't
think so what they would be any country
that would be able to exist after that
after
um several hours or even minutes after
that this is not something that was ever
stated by the leadership of Russia as a
goal of special military operations
is to immediately start negotiations
with any kind of
preconditions and this was stated on
several occasions basically in in every
statement he makes by the president of
Republic of Belarus Mr LoCash lukashenko
has been doing this
but nonetheless reproducing once again
of this
operative paragraph in the text only
takes us
the security council meeting on the 17th
of February this year
foreign
medical sponsors of the resolution it is
intentional an intentional step that
they undertook uh
comprehensive just and Lasting peace
does not contain an appeal to holding
peace negotiations
since the very first days
along prior to the conflict we have been
saying the same thing let me just simply
remind you here that it is thanks to the
efforts made by the president
it was possible to organize several
rounds of negotiations between cave and
Moscow in Belarus and this and the times
gave us all reason for cautious
now breaking this relationship
weapons of mass destruction if these
plans are to be implemented this would
inevitably inevitably lead to use a
spiral of escalation
countless victims and a very real
prospects of global conflict this is not
something you've been allow to happen
and this is precisely what the objective
our imagination is
as soon as possible using peaceful means
but voting upon these amendments we will
consider is a test
interested in obtaining a comprehensive
just and Lasting peace I thank you for
your attention
representative of Belarus
I now give the flow to the distinguished
representative of the Russian Federation
Mr President
more than a year ago yeah
foreign
[Music]
in which people from
the statements made by a number of
countries
[Music]
initiatives on de-escalation and
strengthening confidence issues
we proposed that the US and NATO signed
uh security guarantees we therefore were
thus giving diplomacy
arrogantly spurned by the United States
refused to even discuss our initiatives
which was really had been realized would
have enabled us to avoid what we're
witnessing today
when we suggested that we reach an
agreement
at the time was already going through
ahead to turn Ukraine into a fully
fledged military platform immediately
remembering that do we have any reason
to trust the statements being made by
Western representative today when they
say that
one year after the active stage foreign
contaminated the American European
Elites they're competing against each
other and the number of sanctions
whereas these young sanctions in actual
fact I'm hitting the developing World
in this desire of theirs to defeat
Russia in any way possible they can
sacrifice not just Ukraine they're ready
to plunge the world entire into the
Earth
what is at stake after all is keeping
the United States
or the level of governing the planet
they think it's their Turf as um
they are a one in a wonderful garden
developing States is something that the
collective West does not react to any
peace plan
which is being
negotiating with the Russian leadership
[Music]
today as a result
for survival for the future of our
country our children and our identity
as was also the case eight years
the treacherous and Powerful enemies
involved
abundance and the rest of phobia
appeals
the German tanks once again
[Music]
foreign
why removing the reasons under payment
underpinning the special military
operations
move to the peaceful resolution of the
difference between Russia we can say one
thing the resolution which is submitted
here and so it will be put to the vote
will notice
the question
isolated and that would mean
of course the resolution will be used
yesterday already
foreign
against the draft resolution I thank you
representative of the Russian Federation
I now now give the floor to the this his
Excellency
Joseph Burrell fontellis
High representative for European Affairs
and security policy vice president of
the of the European Commission
[Music]
foreign
the general assembly
distinguished delegates
ladies and gentlemen
this week's marks one year since Russia
started its legal invasion of Ukraine
everybody knows
this was our remained a clear-cut case
of an aggression by a permanent member
of the security Council
and this is Russia
everybody knows
a blatant violation of international law
and the principles of the United Charter
the world needs peace in Ukraine
and the people of Ukraine deserve peace
after so much suffering
but not just any peace
we need a beast grounded in the
principles of the United Nations Charter
that's why we are
In This Very whole
this is what the resolution presented by
Ukraine is about
it's about to reiterate our support for
Ukraine
and to set out the principles for peace
I want to stress it
this war
against Ukraine
is not an European issue
is not about the quest versus Russia
no this illegal War
concerns everyone the north the South
the East the West the whole world
and we are here today to recreate our
support to the Ukraine's sovereignty and
territorial Integrity within each
International recognized borders
as for any member of the United Nations
territorial integrity
these are the principles
that Russia is attacking in Ukraine
every day
these are also the principles we have to
uphold
everywhere
every day
and if we don't condemn and stop
Russia's actions in Ukraine today
this will increase to risk for any other
country elsewhere in the world
to face a similar aggression
no one can feel safe in a world
where the illegal use of force
would be normalized
and there it is the article 51 of the
United Charter
Ukraine has the inherent right to defend
itself
just like any other United Nations
member
Ukraine has the right to defend itself
and protect its population against the
daily shelling by the Russian army
excellencies colleague
European Union has always been a peace
project
and we have been quite successful on
bringing peace to the European continent
and promoting it around the world
it is Central to our our DNA
is in our origin
and when it comes to Ukraine
the real question today are what kind of
Peace yes peace but what kind of Peace
yes and the war but how do we end the
war
how how to achieve this space
the first obvious step for peace
is for Russia to stop its attack
it must end all hostilities
and withdraw its forces and military
equipment for Ukrainian soil
and he must do it immediately completely
and unconditionally
and until then
the European Union will continue to give
Ukraine the support in needs to defend
its population it's also in accordance
with United Nation chart
we will continue to provide humanitarian
and financial assistance
we will work to hold Russia accountable
for its actions and war crimes
and we know from experience
that there can be no lasting peace
without accountability
at the same time
we will continue to support Ukraine's
wish for a justice peace in line with
the United Nations Charter
to
two tracks through two tracks
supporting Ukraine are looking for peace
they go hand in hand
they are not
either or
they are not incompatible by the country
they go hand in hand they are
complementary
you'll know about President zelensky
peace formula
European Union supported
and we will work to mobilize the
broadest possible international support
for it
indeed all of us
all of us have a responsibility to work
for a just a lasting peace
as this resolution table by Ukraine sets
out
and the United Nations Secretary General
has offered his wood offices
to bring an end to this world
and we support him
others have also contributed to the
Diplomatic efforts
the purpose of this resolution is to
support and encourage the efforts to
look for peace
we European Union we have been working
in close cooperation with Ukrainian
partners
throughout the whole Preparatory process
in a transparent and inclusive manner
we have been as inclusive as transparent
as possible
amendments and comments made in good
faith were duly considerate and taken on
board to the extent possible
and we thank delegations that engage
with us
this for sure has a strengthened the
text
but
by putting forward additional amendments
right now
Belarus tries to create confusion on the
process
when the text before the membership is a
simple call for peace in line with
United Nations Charter
these amendments are not made in good
faith
they are manipulative
since they do not reflect the situation
on the ground
which is the unjustified and unprovoked
aggression by Young member State against
another
we will vote
against these amendments
and call on our United Nations member
states to do the same and to support the
draft resolution table by Ukraine
excellencies distinguished delegates the
text before us today
is very much in line with United Nations
Secretary General plea at his briefing
to the general assembly on the 6th of
February
and even today on his speech
as he'd rightly put it
the world needs peace
but peace in line with the United
Nations Charter and international law
and for all reasons simple reasons
evident reasons
I'd ask you to join us in co-sponsoring
this United Nations General Assembly
resolution
and a vote in favor
because this is a moment
every member of the United Nations to
stand and to be counted
thank you
[Music]
I thank the vice president of the
European Commission
now I give the flow to the to his
Excellency Antonio
Deputy Prime Minister and Minister of
Foreign Affairs and international
cooperation of Italy
Mr President
a year ago
you invaded Ukraine
Universe
led to tens of thousands of deaths yeah
destruction of infrastructure
led to the disaster
unbelievable disasters
the rules of international law
alongside the ukrainians who are
suffering at the moment position as
always being very clear
the ongoing aggression is a violation
of the United Nations Charter against
International Security and stability
no country can be safe
if the violation of our common
principles and rules remains an
accountant for
on this anniversary Ukraine still stands
and we stand in full solidarity with the
country and its people
there is attached to their leaves and to
critical infrastructure with devastating
humanitarian costs are inaccessible they
must stop
but we want to work in favor peace
there is no peace without justice
justice is integrity libertad Freedom
Independence Independence for Ukraine no
I pass is no peace without Justice
the Italian government stands for
agreements on specific issues
such as the establishment of a nuclear
safe area around zaporija
and the removal of the Black Sea grain
initiative
unnecessary Indulgence response on these
threats and important steps toward
building Mutual trust and laying the
foundations
of a wider wider dialogue
a comprehensive just a lasting peace in
line with the principle of the charter
of the United Nations is needed as the
resolution brought to the attention of
this element emergency special session
clearly states now more than ever
we need diplomacy also to take in
account of the legitimate concerns and
the expectation of the countries of the
global South which are bearing the
consequences of this conflict
Italy is ready to do its part in this
direction
now is the time to redouble our
Collective support for diplomatic
efforts to achieve this goal
today in this world Parliament where all
the states are represented as equal we
have the opportunity and the moral duty
to demonstrate that we can work together
to achieve this goal adopting a
resolution for peace
with a wedge majority
today we are called human to defend the
rules-based international order
the United Nations
and in this moment at the general
assembly are at the Forefront for peace
and security and human rights
for this reason Italy is a proud
co-sponsor of this draft resolution and
decal on the member states to support a
just Peace by voting yes
vote in favor of the resolution
I thank the Deputy Prime Minister of
Italy
and now I give the flow
to the to her extensive Linda Thomas
Greenfield permanent representative of
the United of the United States to the
United Nations
member of the cabinet of the president
of the United States
thank you Mr President
thank you to the Secretary General
colleagues
today we are gathered to discuss an
important historic resolution
one that will promote diplomacy
dialogue and a lasting peace in Ukraine
the timing of this moment is of course
intentional
one year ago
Russia launched its illegal unprovoked
full-scale Invasion into Ukraine
I remember that day clearly as I know
all of you do too as well
that evening I walked into the United
Nations security Council for an
emergency meeting which the United
States had called for because we
believed that Russia's invasion of
Ukraine was imminent
at this point we had been sounding the
alarm bells for weeks
I had informed the council in no
uncertain terms about the buildup of
troops along the border and what we
thought it meant
secretary blinken had also come to the
security Council and laid out in detail
what we expected would soon unfold
a few days before The Invasion Russia's
Deputy foreign minister told us to and I
quote
stop the Hysteria
on the very night of Russia's Invasion
into Ukraine Russia's representative
said in the security Council that and I
quote occupation of Ukraine is not in
our plan
all Russia did was deny deny deny as we
have heard the Russian PR due again
today
that co-ferry night one year ago today I
asked Russia to stop
to return to its borders to send its
troops tanks and planes back into their
barracks and Hangers to send diplomats
back to the negotiating table
but it was too late
at that exact moment
I joined so many others in the security
Council and around the world to make a
plea
in making a plea for peace
President Putin chose War
this was an illegal unprovoked attack on
Ukraine
but it was also an assault on the United
Nations it struck at the very heart
of the U.N Charter
we all know what happened next and what
is still happening now
the bombing of kindergartens and high
schools
and hospitals the Slaughters of innocent
civilians the worst Refugee crisis in
Europe since World War II an
unprecedented hunger crisis around the
world
threats to nuclear and energy security
families forcibly separated Ukrainian
children relocated to Russia Mass
suffering
crimes against humanity
colleagues this vote is a moment to
remember why we are here of course I
cannot speak for all of you I can only
speak for myself
when I was sworn in for this role it was
exactly one year to the day of Russia's
full-scale invasion of Ukraine
back then I could not have known the
existential threat that the U.N Charter
would face
but I did know what President Biden and
the American people were sending me here
to do
to represent my country to the world yes
but also to uphold the U.N Charter to
engage in dialogue and diplomacy and to
lead us toward a more peaceful more
prosperous planet and that is what I'm
here to do today
and no matter what else you were sent
here to do I know we all share these
same goals in common to represent our
countries to advocate for diplomacy and
to push for peace
this vote is an opportunity to do just
that
we have before us a resolution that
calls on the nations of the world to
support diplomatic efforts to achieve a
comprehensive and Lasting peace in
Ukraine
a piece consistent with the UN Charter
consistent with its fundamental
principles of sovereignty territorial
integrity and self-defense
colleagues this vote will go down in
history
on the one-year anniversary of this
conflict we will see where the nations
of the world stand on the matter of
Peace in Ukraine
earlier this week President Biden
visited Ukraine and he made it clear
where the United States stands
he stood shoulder to shoulder with
president zielinski to remind the world
that one year later
heave still stands
Ukraine still stands and America still
stands with Ukraine
I too visited Ukraine late last year and
while I learned a great deal in my
meetings and discussions the most
powerful lessons I took away were in the
faces of the Ukrainian people
and president zielinski I saw resolve I
saw a leader determined to defend his
people and defend his country for as
long as it takes
in the faces of refugees and victims
I saw suffering
deep sorrow
unimaginable pain was etched into their
visages
it is hard to overstate how much
unnecessary anguish and pain President
Putin has caused
but it was in the faces of Ukrainian
children where I found Hope
I met a 10 year old girl Malena who
lived in a facility where displaced
families were gathering to prepare for
the cold winter a facility that had once
been hit by Russian missiles
and I asked Melina what she wanted to do
when the war was over
and she smiled
she told me simply that she wanted to go
back to school and see her best friend
again
her face beamed with hope
I will never forget her shining eyes
colleagues we should never give up on
hope we should never give up on the
potential for diplomacy or the power of
dialogue or the urgency of peace
we now have an opportunity to vote for
that peace and to vote to uphold the U.N
Charter once more
a U.N Charter which stands for
sovereignty and territorial integrity a
U.N Charter that stands for the inherent
right of self-defense
and a U.N Charter which aims to maintain
International Peace and security and end
the scourge of War
so colleagues I urge you to vote against
against any and all hostile amendments
that seek to undermine the U.N Charter
and ignore the truth of this War I urge
you instead
to vote Yes in support of this
resolution as it stands to promote
diplomacy and dialogue
yes diplomacy and dialogue to promote
cooperation on the threats to Global
Food security energy Finance the
environment nuclear security and safety
to defend the U.N Charter we have all
signed up to protect and to support a
just and Lasting peace in Ukraine thank
you very much
[Music]
I thank the distinguished member of the
cabinet of the president of the United
States
and now I give the Flow To Her
Excellency Melanie Jolie Minister
Foreign Affairs of Canada
thank you yeah
means against
and it needs to end
called on today as equal members of the
general assembly
to once again
full support
principles of the charter of the United
Nations
to ensure that these purposes and
principles underlie a comprehensive just
and Lasting peace in Ukraine
and to affirm our support for
international law
and for accountability when the law is
broken
we have before us today a resolution
that does this
text has been drafted to reflect the
views and concerns of members from all
regions
for these reasons Canada believes that
this draft resolution deserves the
support of each and every member of this
assembly
Mr President
as we mark this Grim occasion
the Russians Federation further Invasion
an illegal war of aggression against
Ukraine rages is on
Russia is continuing its missile attacks
against Ukraine in cities killing
Ukrainian civilians and destroying the
country's critical infrastructure
schools and hospitals have not been
spared thousands of Ukrainian civilians
have been killed more have been injured
and more than 14 million ukrainians have
been forced to flee their homes
last week I was in Kiev
and I heard firsthand some of the
heartbreaking choices this war has
forced on the people of Ukraine
these stories remind us of the true and
brutal nature of Russia's War
this is not and has never been a
so-called special military operation
President Putin is entirely responsible
for this war
and his latest address proves that he
remains unmoored from this reality
his address was nothing more than
recycled absurdities as repeated by the
Russian Ambassador today in this chamber
and his suspension of the start treaty
is nothing short of Reckless
this is total war aimed at punishing and
destroying the free and dependent and
Sovereign Nation of Ukraine and its
people
and President Putin will not succeed
Mr President
too long to support Ukraine for as long
as necessary
until reconstruction
training like military material and
humanitarian assistance
will be double if not more we know that
for reconstruction to be inclusive and
enduring it must address both the
physical and invisible impacts of
Putin's War
and so we must tackle the psychological
marks of the war on Ukraine's people
with the same seriousness and urgency as
the physical scars
the impacts of the war on food and
energy security supply chains and
inflation have rippled across every
corner of the world and have hit the
most vulnerable the hardest
Russia's war of choice is estimated to
cost the global economy 2.8 trillion
dollars
51 million more people were pushed into
poverty during the first three months of
the war alone because of the soaring
food and energy prices triggered by
Russia's invasion
these are lives and livelihoods
destroyed by President Putin's war of
choice and its impacts and we have heard
the calls from many countries here in
this chamber about the disastrous
impacts of this war on their peoples and
their economies
but peace has to be built on security
and justice
and Russia needs to listen and respond
to the demands of this assembly to stop
its war of aggression
is
session
of all States
including its territorial Waters
military forces from the territory of
Ukraine yeah
through its words and actions Russia is
showing us very plainly that it does not
respect this assembly and the members
represented here
more than that it has expanded its
illegal war of aggression
it has used its veto
it's power
it's privilege to sideline the security
Council
it has attempted to legally Annex
Ukraine's territory through shamra
faranda
it has pedal misinformation and
conspiracy theories online in our
countries and in this chamber
it has doubled down on its attacks
against Ukraine's critical
infrastructure in clear violation of
international humanitarian law
this is not the sign of a country that
respects its obligation or its fellow
member states
Russia would have you believe that this
is about forcing you to choose sides
today's vote
is not about choosing sides
it's about choosing peace
a comprehensive just and Lasting peace
in Ukraine it is about choosing to
uphold the U.N Charter
it is about respecting the right of
every state in this chamber to chart
their own future
it is about choosing rules over chaos
and clearly stating that no one today
and in the future can disregard the
principles of sovereignty and
territorial integrity
Canada encourages every member of this
assembly to choose peace and vote in
favor of this resolution thank you so
much
thank the distinguished minister of
Canada
now I give the flow to his Excellency
Jose Manuel Alvarez Bueno
Minister's European union and
cooperation of Spain
since the beginning of the aggression of
the Russian Federation against Ukraine
today
once again
with a broad majority of this aggression
it's important it is
foreign
a world that is more insecure and more
viable
yes
and all of this Russia is violating the
universal Declaration of Human Rights
foreign
the country and we have committed 250
million euros for the Reconstruction
through multilateral agencies
forgetting the needs of other partners
we are increasing our cooperation budget
for these areas
Global consequences
the financial crisis and the energy
crisis following the pandemics
the worst humanitarian situation
of the planet in Africa in the Middle
East
foreign
thank you very much
thank the distinguished minister of
Spain
and now I give the flow to the to his
Excellency mariju Adolfo Bokaro Flores
Minister of Foreign Affairs of Guatemala
senior president Mr President
excellences
I had the opportunity to be in kids
that this war has produced
for this invitation to the resumed 11
special session of the general assembly
of the United Nations
of the Russian Federation against
Ukraine
in order to address one of the greatest
crises at the global level
this is where we get the ideas
they have particular responsibilities
and obligations because maintaining
International Peace and security is a
duty on all of us that's why we support
and believe that the language of the
draft resolution is coherent and in
accordance with the principles of the
charter of the United Nations
to sovereignty Independence and the
territorial Integrity of Ukraine
assembly authority to approve this
resolution
crimes that shock the consciousness of
humanity that we've all witnessed
foreign
[Music]
peace and Justice in favor of Ukraine
thank you
I thank the distinguished minister of
Guatemala and now I give the flow to
Hurricane
Minister of Foreign and European Affairs
of Slovenia
president of the general assembly
Secretary General excellencies ladies
and gentlemen
in 1945 United Nations were created to
save succeeding Generations from the
scourge of War
you and Charlie reflected our Collective
woe to refrain from the use of Armed
Force against the territorial Integrity
or political independence of any state
aggression violation of territorial
integrity and illegal annexation of
sovereign territories should have no
place in the world order of the 21st
Century
yet the principles Insurance in the U.N
Charter are being blatantly violated and
all those who hoped for a peaceful just
and prosperous World almost eight
decades ago would have been deeply
disappointed
ladies and gentlemen a year ago Ukraine
a sovereign country was attacked by its
neighbor the Russian Federation
sadly despite the Wide International
condemnation and calls for the immediate
withdrawal the war still continues along
with its devastating consequences
especially for the civilian population
I commence the bravery and courage of
the Ukrainian people
Slovenia knows from its own historical
experience what it means to fight for
your land
we know what is at stake when somebody
uses Force to deny your Independence and
sovereignty
and although we slovenians are deeply
concerned about the wider security
political and Economic Consequences of
the Russian aggression we also remain
committed to assisting Ukraine and its
people
we stand in solidarity with the women
men and children whose lives have been
changed Forever by this unjustified War
we are deeply concerned about growing
numbers of Civilian casualties and the
rest and testimonies of sexual and
gender-based violence used as a weapon
of War
especially heartbreaking are the
accounts from children
millions are displaced many of them at
risk of human trafficking exploitation
conflict related sexual violence and
forced deportations
they are deeply traumatized by the war
and the violence their childhood is over
forever
the deliberate attacks of the Russian
army on civilian population and critical
infrastructure constitute most serious
crimes that should not go unpunished all
those responsible must be held to
account
Slovenia supports all efforts to end
impunity for the perpetrators of
international law violations especially
the most serious ones
the principle of accountability must be
upheld since it is the only foundation
for the life when the war and its
atrocities end
it is the only foundation of Justice the
only foundation for reconciliation and
the only foundation which enables the
victims to move forward excellencies
our strong support goes to the efforts
by the U.N Secretary General as well as
the member states that promote a
comprehensive just and Lasting peace in
Ukraine we need to redouble our
diplomatic efforts to de-escalate the
current situation and end the fighting
through political dialogue negotiation
and other peaceful means
all peace efforts which take into
account who is the aggressor and who is
its victim deserve our support
Slovenia would like to stress that
International or peaceful settlement of
disputes and the respect for the
decisions of international tribunals as
well as their full implementation are
the building blocks of a world that is
peaceful stable and prosperous Mr
President this war reminds us all just
how globally connected and
interdependent we are
its consequences are felt all over the
world
and I would like to State this very
clearly these are not consequences of
our support for Ukraine no consequences
of our reaction to the illegal
aggression these are the consequences of
the aggression itself the the soul and
full responsibility of the aggressor
with a staggering rice in food and
energy prices and the looming inflation
millions of people are faced with severe
challenges disruptions to food supply
chains energy and finance systems around
the globe affect us all
but at least developed in low-income
countries suffer the most
and we all must do better
I would like to reassure our friends and
partners worldwide that reacting to the
Russian aggression on Ukraine does not
mean that the other conflicts crisis or
challenges have forgotten
a humanitarian response to other
situations of need is not being
diminished our solidarity and
responsibility remain firm we applaud
Ukraine for launching the initiative
grain from kirane despite the war
Ukraine extended its hand across the sea
to the people in need and those facing
food insecurity
to facilitate the grain exports Slovenia
has joined efforts to help and support
these important initiative with its own
contribution
ladies and gentlemen
let me conclude by saying it once more
any unprovoked invasion of any sovereign
country is unacceptable
violations of the international legal
order that we have worked so hard to
build cannot and must not become our new
normal
with that
Slovenia gives its strong support for
today's resolution on principles
underlying a comprehensive just and
Lasting peace in Ukraine in line with
the U.N Charter thank you
I thank the distinguished minister of
Slovenia
now I give the flow to his Excellency
almost Reigns hello Minister of Foreign
Affairs of Estonia
Mr President Excellence is ladies and
gentlemen
a year ago
the world watched in horror how Russia
launched its full-scale brutal
unprovoked and illegal war of aggression
against Ukraine
and let remind that Russia has hooled
war against Ukraine for almost nine
years
a permanent member of the security
Council whose mandate in that seat is
rightfully under challenge
demonstrated its complete disrespect for
the rules-based international order
by invading its Sovereign neighbor
Ukraine Russia has trampled upon the
fundamental principles of the U.N
Charter including the obligation to
refrain from using Force against another
state
Russia has completely ignored several
calls by the general assembly to stop
its aggression and the legally binding
order of the icj from last March to
suspend immediately its military
operation as they call in Ukraine
there have been no signs of
de-escalation and we see the opposite as
Russia's new offensive is unfolding
Russia continues to punish Ukraine for
choosing its own Sovereign path
as we speak Russian bombs continue
targeting critical infrastructure
including energy and water systems with
the aim of breaking the Ukrainian will
by causing immense pain and suffering to
civilians we have witnessed righteous
massive air strikes on civilian sites
often intensely populated areas
abounding evidence shows that the
aggressor has also used sexual and
gender-based violence as a weapon of War
the this brutal war of aggression has
already caused at least 19
000 civilian casualties approximately
1300 of them children
nearly 13 and a half million people have
had to flee the homes while entire
cities have been reduced to Rubble over
17 million people in Ukraine are in need
of humanitarian assistance
over 1.6 million ukrainians have been
deported among them thousands of
children for illegal adoptions
truth of that
should prevail
therefore I call on countries worldwide
to recognize Russia's war of aggression
against Ukraine as a genocide
Putin has not kept secret
about his intent to annihilate Ukrainian
nation and State
let us be clear Russia's full-scale war
of aggression impacts us all and
therefore it is our duty to restore
peace and Justice and not let the
aggressor go unpunished
aggression as an instrument of
international relations must be
completely discredited Russia must be
held accountable for all atrocity crimes
committed in Ukraine including for the
crime of aggression for this we need to
establish of an international special
tribunal to hold Russian political and
Military leadership to account the U.N
can protect the common values of states
enshrined in the un's charter by denying
Mr Putin the opportunity to hide in the
judicial loophole as we know impunity
today will only lead to more crimes
tomorrow
so Mr Putin
you will be on the tribunal and pay for
crimes
you have done
Putin
must be Mr president
Ukraine deserves peace
peace that preserves Ukraine's
territorial integrity and upholds its
sovereignty in accordance with you and
Charter and international law
a comprehensive just and Lasting power
peace is the immediate
complete and unconditional withdrawal of
the occupying forces of the Russian
Federation from the territory of Ukraine
within its internationally recognized
borders
sure borders cannot be an
appoint peace plan put forward by
Ukraine and commit to working together
towards its implementation
today's resolution is an important
bailing block on this path its
International Community will not stop
the Russian aggression the global impact
of the war on food Security Financial
system energy and environment will
become even more devastating
stop that victim State also needs
power to defend
Estonia has given one percent of its GDP
to military aid
help Ukraine to defend itself
Mr President February 24th is a symbolic
date for estonians we celebrate the
anniversary of the Estonian declaration
of independence from 1918. last year's
anniversary reminded Us in the most
brutal manner of fragile Independence
and freedom can be
on behalf of the Estonian people I want
to pay tribute to the immeasurable
resolve and resilience of Ukrainian
people they are not only defending the
country and people but also our common
values International legal order and the
U.N Charter
it is our duty as humans
to keep standing behind Ukraine
in my
visits last year to Ukraine
I can say that ukrainians are truly the
bravest people
on Earth their colleagues righteous
destructive and genocidal war of
aggression that is fueled by their
imperialist Ambitions has to be stopped
therefore Estonia votes for the U.N
General Assembly resolution principles
underlying a comprehensive just and
logic peace in Ukraine and I Call On The
World U.N Community to do the same slavo
crani
I thank the minister for foreign affairs
of Estonia and I now give the floor to
his Excellency Ilia darcheshvili
Minister for foreign affairs of Georgia
Mr President excellencies
ladies and gentlemen
the United Nations was founded to save
succeeding Generations from the scratch
a war unfortunately this course has been
repeatedly challenged
Russia's war of aggression against
Ukraine has been a Brazen attack on the
entire International rules-based order
shattering Global Peace and security
architecture it has resulted in grave
humanitarian consequences loss of lives
and mass displacement after one year we
gathered again to stand for the
principles of the charter this
organization is founded on for the
fundamental norms and principles of the
international law dear colleagues it has
been almost 15 years since Russia's
full-scale military aggression against
Georgia and the consequent occupation of
20 of its territories in blatant
violation of the principles of the U.N
Charter Helsinki final act at the
charter of Paris Russia occupied aprasia
and srinivale regions of Georgia remain
in the constant source of insecurity due
to Russia's illegalizations military
basis excellencies Georgia remains
committed to peaceful resolution of
Russia Georgia conflict that relies on
the occupation of two Georgian regions
by Russia on the one hand and
Reconciliation and confidence building
between the communities across the
occupation lines on the other while
Georgia remains in full compliance with
the EU mediated 12 August 2008 ceasefire
agreements Consolidated approach of the
International Community is essential in
urging Russia to comply with its
obligations and the ceasefire agreements
and withdraw its military forces from
the territory of Georgia and this regard
Georgia tries to utilize the existing
negotiations formats of the Geneva and
the national discussions dear colleagues
Ukraine needs peace our countries and
our people need peace the world needs
peace we Face the global challenges of
unprecedented scale climate change
natural disasters pandemics terrorism
and conventional threats that require
our joint efforts our cooperation
there is so much the United Nations can
and have to do we need to do so for our
children and we need to do so for the
future Generations but we succeed only
if each and every member of this
organization stands firm in defending
its founding principles we proudly
recommit it to and the U.N 75
declaration I would like to underline
the importance of the peace formal
initiative and reiterate Georgia's
support to it this initiative goes
beyond the restoration of peace and
territory Integrity of Ukraine and has
more overarching aim of defending the
core values of the United Nations
distinguished delegates Georgia fully
aligns itself with the efforts of
international organizations as standard
solidarity with the people of Ukraine in
these trying times the government of
Georgia initiated and delivered
significant human right and support to
ukrainians on the ground as well as the
displaced persons from Ukraine residing
in Georgia excellencies
let me also use this opportunity to
voice Georgia's strong support to the
drought resolution before us today
which once again sends a clear signal
and defending all the core principles of
this Organization principles of
sovereignty and territorial integrity
and calls for a comprehensive just and
Lasting piece in line with the U.N
Charter I would like to conclude by once
again reiterating our strong and
unwavering support to Ukraine's
territorial integrity and sovereignty
within its International internationally
recognized borders I thank you
I thank the minister for foreign affairs
of Georgia
and I'll give the floor to his
Excellency Ian bork Minister for foreign
affairs and European Affairs and trade
of Malta
Secretary General president of the
general assembly excellencies
the general assembly this call today to
focus on the principles underlying a
comprehensive just and Lasting peace in
Ukraine
we remain Gravely concerned about the
ongoing war of aggression of the Russian
Federation against Ukraine
and reiterate that it is in violation of
the U.N Charter its values and the
rules-based international order
the International Community is
continuously horrified by the daily
reports including by the U.N independent
International Commission of inquiry on
Ukraine of attacks against civilians and
civilian infrastructure including homes
hospitals and schools
violence including sexual and
gender-based violence against women and
children and the use of torture
Russia's disregard for international law
must be condemned and denounced without
reservation
not withstanding The Bravery shown by
the Ukrainian people
the Russian Federation is further
pushing Ukraine into a grave
humanitarian crisis
40 percent of Ukraine's population is in
dire need of assistance
nearly 8 million people have fled to
neighboring countries
and 5.3 million are internally displaced
or unable to live illegally annexed
regions
the discovery
of mass graves in areas regained from
Russian occupation further underlines
the gravity of the situation
we reiterate that All Those who commit
Unleashed violations of international
humanitarian law and human rights law
must be held accountable
Malta will continue to support all
efforts by Ukraine and the International
Community to this end
Mr President
at every opportunity we have emphasized
the implications of this aggression on
the region the continent and globally
we have put the spotlight on the
humanitarian catastrophe that the
Ukrainian people are forced to endure
and the sufferings that the war has
brought to people around the world
we must continue to call on the Russian
Federation to withdraw all its forces
from the territory of Ukraine without
further delay
and to seek a peaceful resolution of all
issues in accordance with international
law and the principles of the charter
Mr President
military iterates that halting this war
of aggression against Ukraine at once is
the only way forward
there's no other way
ensuring accountability for perpetrators
of atrocity crimes committed and justice
for victims including victims of sexual
violence and the forced deportation of
children from Ukraine are a priority
we also reiterate our support to the
resolution 11-5 on the veterans of
Remedy and reparation for aggression
against Ukraine
Mr President
a fundamental principle in Article 2 of
the U.N Charter is the rejection of an
International System where might is
right
all United Nations member states today
must stop
think and Ponder on the gravity of the
current situation and what might be the
result if they don't speak out and
reaffirm by their vote the importance of
safeguarding a rules-based international
order
and the principles of the charter
it is our individual and Collective
responsibility and this particular time
to fight for these principles with all
our might and support of the UN Charter
and Malta therefore
urges all member states to support the
draft resolution being presented before
the general assembly let's vote Yes for
peace thank you
I thank the minister for foreign and
European Affairs and trade of Malta and
I'll give the floor to his Excellency
Peter lounski tiefenthal Deputy Minister
for foreign affairs of Austria
Mr President
excellencies distinguished delegates
We Gather here today to Mark a somber
anniversary
almost one year has passed since Russia
launched an unprovoked
and unjustifiable wove aggression
against its neighbor Ukraine
one year of human suffering
one year of missiles and drones raining
down
on Ukrainian civilians
I witnessed the destruction and horrors
of this war myself upon my visit to
Ukraine late last year
everyone who has visited Ukraine in the
last 12 months
cannot return without having been deeply
touched
on a human level
and so have I
visiting Kiev and European looking into
the faces of small children
and their teachers
being grateful for a simple generator
so that the local kindergarten can be
heated
or meeting citizens standing in front of
their destroyed houses
being grateful for basic equipment such
as power Banks
so that they can stay in touch
with their loved ones
their faces are a reflection of the
cruelty senseless and human tragedy of
this war
we are impressed by the tremendous
courage and perseverance
ukrainians are demonstrating to us
their destiny is Our obligation
he said it one year ago and we repeat it
today
an attack against one member of this
organization
is an attack on all of us
that is what the U.N Charter in our
system
of collective security implies
Austria relies on the respect and
implementation of international law
treaties and Customs for its security
that is exactly why we cannot stand on
the sidelines
while the basic principles of our legal
and security order are under threat
we are never politically neutral and we
will never remain silent when the
sovereignty
territorial integrity and Independence
of a state is attacked
in the past year we've seen an
overwhelming support at the general
assembly to call on Russia to stop this
war
to stop the suffering of Ukraine's
population
to stop the nuclear threats
and to stop the blatant breaches of the
U.N Charter including the illegal
attempt to Annex whole regions of
Ukraine
we are encouraged by this overwhelming
show of solidarity with Ukraine
in the face of a brutal armed attack
and by the overwhelming support for
international law and for the UN Charter
we also Express grave concerns about the
global consequences of this war
about the impact on food security the
rise in Energy prices the mass
displacement of persons
it is crucial to alleviate the global
consequences of this world
recommend the Secretary General for his
leadership
and the efforts of the government of
turkey in facilitating the Black Sea
grain initiative
as well as the grain from Ukraine
initiative Austria fully supports its
continued renewal as well as its full
unhindered implementation
and we've listened to concerns and
understand that we must not lose sight
of other crisis which is why Austria is
continuing its strong and persistent
financial support
to humanitarian efforts around the world
Austria stands in full solidarity with
Ukraine the Ukrainian government and the
Ukrainian people
Austria has bilaterally provided 124
million euros in humanitarian assistance
with focus on winterization
's support and basic needs and so much
more has already been done
in the past year we've seen millions of
lives uprooted in millions of people
fleeing their home to seek shelter
we would like to express our sincere
gratitude for the outstanding support of
the International Community for the
Ukrainian people and for the support of
Civil Society not only in Austria but in
all of its neighboring countries
we must also be clear that there is no
peace without Justice and without
accountability
Ukrainian cities such as Butcher and
Maria pool have become synonymous for
unspeakable human suffering
atrocities committed against the
civilian population
rape torture extrajudicial killings all
of these crimes must be investigated and
perpetrators held to account
we fully support all efforts to do so
including by the international criminal
court and the U.N Commission of inquiry
based in Vienna
one aspect that Austria contends in
condemns in the strongest possible terms
are the repeated implicit but
unmistakable threats made by Russia on
the use of nuclear weapons nuclear risks
are higher than they have been in
decades and they are potentially
devastating and Global humanitarian and
environmental consequences are a direct
security threat to the entire
International Community
we welcome efforts by the International
Community to work together foremost
through the iaea to secure the nuclear
energy facilities that have become
Targets in this world
we welcome proposals by its director
General Rafael Grossi to this effect and
are grateful for the tireless work of
the iaea teams present on the ground in
all nuclear power plants in Ukraine
all this underscores the utmost urgency
of progress on nuclear disarmament and
of moving away from the nuclear
deterrence Paradigm which is fraud with
immense risks and uncertainties at the
expense of the common security of all
Humanity
the International Community must come
together to ensure that the taboo
against any use of nuclear weapons is
not broken and that any threat or use
remains inadmissible
Excellence is distinguished delegates
Ukraine like every independent state and
member of the United Nations is entitled
to the stability and security of a
comprehensive just and Lasting peace a
peace based on international law and on
the U.N Charter
we call on Russia once again to stop
this war withdraw its troops from the
whole territory of Ukraine and end the
bloodshed
the United Nations and other
multilateral organizations such as the
organization for security and
cooperation in Europe in Vienna are
indispensable fora for dialogue and
peace in which member states
which can resolve disputes through
dialogue is possible we must strengthen
and preserve these organizations and
enable them to fulfill their role the
resolution that will be adopted tomorrow
in this GA Hall
aims at an end to aggression Against The
Sovereign Nation and then to the global
consequences of this war a comprehensive
just and Lasting peace based on the
principles of the UN Charter
Austria therefore strongly supports this
text and we encourage all of you to vote
Yes on the general assembly resolutions
thank you
I thank the deputy Minister for foreign
affairs of Austria and I'll give the
floor to his Excellency Jerusalem
Secretary of State Ministry of Foreign
Affairs and European integration of the
Republic of Moldova
Mr President distinguished
Representatives
it's a deeply regrettable that the large
scale and the illegal invasion of the
Russian Federation against Ukraine has
already been going on for a year
in view of this it is more than critical
that we strongly support the resumption
of the special emergency session of the
UN General Assembly to discuss and make
decision with the principles underlying
the achievement of comprehensive just
and hosting peace in Ukraine
distinguished delegates 12th month of
unprovoked and unjust law of aggression
have killed thousands of innocent people
and pushed millions of ukrainians to
flee their homes
12th month of the Brighton violation of
the event chapter and the principles of
the international law by one of the
permanent member members of the U.N
security Council whose primary
responsibility is to maintain peace and
security a worldwide
Russia's illegal and unprovoked attack
continues a direct threats to the
sovereignty and Independence of Ukraine
has destabilized European security and
undermine global stability
we express our utmost admiration to all
ukrainians for their courage resilience
and inner power to pursue this fight for
survival Justice
and Freedom the Republic of Moldova
expressed its compassion with the
families of the victims and stands in
solidarity with the people of Ukraine in
this tough times
the Republic of Moldova has firmly
demonstrated his commitment and
engagement in the insurance protection
for those seeking the refugee in our
country
we continue to offer support and shelter
to Ukrainian people who fled the war
approximately 700
000 Ukrainian refugees have entered the
territory of the Republic of Moldova
since the beginning of the war in
Ukraine and other 18
000 remain to date in the country almost
half of them being children all of them
with a special protection
in this way the government of the
Republic of Moldova recently adopted
their decision to introduce from 1st of
March the temporary protection mechanism
for the Ukrainian refugees thus
contributing to a more efficient
management of the migration flows
legalization and access the fundamental
rights
we will also continue to provide
humanitarian support to Ukraine and
facility trending of goods through the
solidarity Lanes which are key to
ensuring food security and the global
level
Moldova has also failed this security
consequences of the war in Ukraine at
least four missiles targeting Ukraine
across our airspace and several
incidents of LaSalle's debris landing on
our territory have happened
my country is also exposed to hybrid
threats and various means of pressure
we are committed to further countering
this risk in a systemic legal and
peaceful manner
Mr President
it is our moral duty as an International
Community to continue supporting Ukraine
Ukraine is faced is fighting today to
keep all of us safe to keep Europe safe
this world should not continue endlessly
we stress the need to ensure the
accountability for the atrocities
killing of civilians and damaging the
public infrastructure through timely
fair and independent investigations both
at the national and international level
this is of tremendous importance not
only for ensuring justice for all
victims of this war but also for
preventing future crimes
Mr President
Ukraine and the entire International
Community needs a way out of this war
which triggered multiple crises we
believe that the peaceful map proposed
by President zielinski is a
comprehensive package and has all
necessary ingredients to achieve a
lasting peace and prevent Another War
we also considered that the United
Nations needs to play a role in reaching
and securing peace in this regard the
Republic of Moldova has co-sponsored the
draft of resolution Yuan charity
principles underlying comprehensive just
and Lasting peace in Ukraine
which we hope will gang the support of
this August assembly
in conclusion we reiterate our call for
Russian Federation to the immediately
stop its war of aggression against
Ukraine withdraw all its forces and
military equipment from the Ukrainian
territory and respect ukrainians
sovereignty Independence and territory
Integrity Within
International
recognized borders thank you
I thank the secretary of state of the
Republic of Moldova
and I'll give the floor to his
Excellency Bernardo Evo Cruz Vice
Minister for foreign affairs of Portugal
thank you Mr President we align our
statement with the one delivered by the
European Union and would like to add the
following points in our national
capacity
this week we mark one year since the
Russian leadership decided to invade
Ukraine and wage war against a sovereign
country a decision taken and implemented
let us not forget while the security
Council was in session discussing ways
to prevent it
since then we are counting 365 days of
unprovoked and unjustifiable aggression
which grossly violates the international
law and in particular the charter of the
United Nations we condemned Russia in
the strongest terms for this war and for
in the irresponsible nuclear rhetoric
the loss of life and human suffering
caused by this war cannot let us
indifferent
the humanitarian situation is dramatic
have integrated the worst Refugee crisis
in Europe since World War II
figures are staggering thousands have
died and millions left the country or
became internally displaced
the strategy of relentlessly attack
Critical infrastructures with the
tremendous impact on civilian
populations is particularly repressive
Portugal supports the sovereignty
Independence unity and territorial
territory Integrity of the Ukraine we
will continue to provide assistance to
its government and people both
bilaterally and in the framework of the
European Union and of the United Nations
as long as it takes
Portugal is fast approaching the 600 the
6 000 requests for temporary protection
on our humanitarian Aid continues to
grow we are also engaged in the
Reconstruction of schools namely in
disaster Rich region
the president beyond the Ukraine the
consequences of the war are felt more
severely by the most vulnerable
population
suffering from a combination of impacts
of food Fuel and financial crisis this
emergency special session presents an
occasion to highlight the importance
role of the United Nations that has been
played in mitigation the global
consequences of the war
600 million people worldwide live in
food insecurity a figure that tends to
get worse the Black Sea grain initiative
has so far allowed the shipment of more
than 21 million tons of brain reaching
regions where it's most needed
harkable achieved by the U.N also due to
the personal commitment of Secretary
General guttersh
we also take part we all hope that all
parties will acknowledge the crucial
importance of this initiative ensuring
its continuity
many agencies funds and programs in the
UN system are doing everything within
their capacity to address the global
consequences of the war let me just
mention a few of them the International
Organization for migrants dealing with
an unparalleled Refugee crisis in a
remarkable way
the international atomic energy agency
because this war has sadly revived the
dreads of a nuclear disaster
the UNICEF which has sought to minimize
the impact of war in 0.75
0.7.5 million Ukrainian children
the Human Rights Council who
establishing of an independent
International Commission of inquiry on
the Ukraine is of Paramount importance
the world food program and the office of
the coordination of humanitarian Affairs
are among many of those working that
have made a really difference so far
Mr President since the beginning of the
war this General Assembly has approved
several resolutions with the support of
a significant majority of its members
we must remain unite convening our
condemnation of this war convening that
the achievements of comprehensive just
and Lasting peace would indeed
constitute a significant and necessary I
would add contribution to the strengths
of International Peace and security as
mentioned in the draft resolution before
us
We Gather here today to protect the
multilateral system
and to uphold our respect for
international law for human rights and
the peaceful resolution of disputes
between states furthermore Portugal is
fully committed to ensure accountability
and will continue to support initiatives
aiming at preventing violations fighting
impunity and
providing reparations for the Ukraine
Portugal supports all meanful efforts to
bring an end to this war of aggression
the path for peace is for the Russian
Federation to act in accordance to the
U.N Charter and respect the sovereignty
of the Ukraine redrawing from its
entirely territory we believe that the
draft resolution before us is an
important step in that direction and we
encourage all member states to support
it thank you very much
I thank the vice Minister for foreign
affairs of Portugal
and I'll give the floor to his
Excellency Martin a Olson permanent
Secretary of State Ministry of Foreign
Affairs of Iceland
Mr President
Iceland aligns itself with a statement
to be to be made tomorrow by Denmark on
the on behalf of the naughty countries
this is a sad moment
the general assembly of the United
Nations convenes in an emergency session
to mark that a year has passed since
Russia launched its unprovoked and
unjustifiable full-scale invasion of
Ukraine
Russia
a permanent member of the security
Council has with this horrendous Act of
aggression assaulted not only Ukraine
without common institutions are common
values
and our basic human rights
right and shrines in the very United
Nations Charter and the universal
Declaration of Human Rights
rights we have all subscribed to
rights that Russia has all also
subscribed to
our admirate our admiration for the
courage and the resilience of the people
of Ukraine grows with each day
they valiantly defend their country
their sacrifice and suffering
must not be in vain
the foreign minister of Estonia
said here a while ago
that the Ukrainian people were the
bravest people
of the world I cannot only subscribe to
this
I can add to it
as their Captain the captain of Team
Ukraine president selinski is a bravest
leader of the world
and has
changed the whole meaning of the world
leadership
Mr President
the solution to end the war
is straightforward Russia can and must
stop this war today and withdraw all its
forces from Ukraine in full respect of
Ukraine's recognized right to
Independence sovereignty territorial
integrity and self-defense
let us also be reminded that ending the
war
is only the first step
to establish
just and Lasting peace for Ukraine is
also of critical importance
Russia must and will be held to account
for its actions
accountability for international crimes
committed within the context of the
world including the crime of aggression
is vital
it's vital to ensure Justice and
reparations
there can't be no impunity
accountability is indeed the only way to
ensure a lasting peace
Mr President
the Warfare contacted by Russia against
the member state is an act of aggression
that affects all of us
humanitarian concerns food security
Economic Development all these important
issues that weigh so much on our agenda
are hit by this senseless War
to sit idle on the fence or even support
the aggressor is beyond comprehension
it is our Collective responsibility to
end this war defend Ukraine and stand up
for the values and principle principles
that underpaint the U.N Charter and the
work of this organization
that we the peoples owe to the people of
Ukraine and all other innocent victims
presently facing this courts of armed
conflict all over the world
that we owe to the previous generations
that built the system of international
law and the rule-based order from the
ruins of two world wars and dead
Unforgettable Horrors
and that we owe to our children the
generations that we follow
Mr President Iceland remains unwavering
in its support and solidarity with
Ukraine we are committed to play our
part including in our role as the chair
of the Council of Europe
and we are a proud co-sponsor of the
Resolute draft resolution on just and
Lasting peace in Ukraine
I call on all member states to support
the draft resolution and vote against
the Belarus amendment of course I thank
you Mr President
I thank the distinguished permanent
secretary Secretary of State of Iceland
and now I give the floor to Hurricane
Georgina Guin foreign policy director of
the Minister of Foreign Affairs of Costa
Rica
Mr President
Costa Rica is attending this new
emergency session of the general
assembly one year after illegal illegal
and unjustified
[Music]
as Humanity we all face
foreign
[Music]
such as climate change
weapon systems ever more powerful and
advanced as well as the military use of
artificial intelligence and the
development of autonomous weapons and
systems
destabilizing technologies
justice for all foreign
now it's time to deliver
peace
opportunity to peace thank you very much
I think they distinguished foreign
policy director of Costa Rica and now I
give the flow to the representative of
Oman speaking on behalf of the gulf
cooperation Council
foreign